there is no shortcut there's no hack
there's no tip there's just the work
people don't like pain it's why most
people don't have six-packs
I love being self aware I suck in a lot
of things I just don't think about them
every single thing I've ever done in my
life people thought was stupid until
they get it the motivation watch a top
10 with the lead nation what's up please
nation at 7 I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be part of your
daily success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being born in the Soviet Union
hustlin as a kid selling flowers and
baseball cards to growing his family
wine business founding vaynermedia and
becoming one of the most sought-after
speakers alive he's Gary Vaynerchuk and
here's my take on his top ten rules to
success volume 15 also if you want to
know a Gary Vee and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next two hundred and fifty four
days I will send you a morning video for
free to help you build your confidence
the link to join is in the description
below the reason people aren't patient
is they value other people's opinions
too much
okay let's take it off with rule number
one grind if you've got debt or have to
put a roof over your head or somebody
else then you work whatever job is
paying you that but I'm asking you what
are you doing from 6:00 p.m. to midnight
and if you have to go build slowly your
portfolio your Shopify store your
Instagram account your YouTube channel
your content like like wouldn't you be
pumped if I told you for the next four
years it's tough and you don't watch as
much Netflix and Sports and hanging out
but then you get to live happy for the
rest of your life everybody in theory
would sign up for that the reality is a
lot of people don't want to grind for
four years like people don't like pain
it's why most people don't have
six-packs
I mean that I mean that there's a lot of
people here who want to be a better
shape you just don't want to workout you
just don't want to eat well it rule
number two
love yourself I love being self-aware I
suck in a lot of things I just don't
think about them like I can't read for
sure I interrupt people when I interview
them 24/7 every but I'm super pissed on
the internet about that not good cuz I
already know what the person saying I
can't help but I'm sorry there's plenty
of things that I'm not good at I love
self-awareness I like it's kept me so
happy like you know I'm not upset of
myself that I'm selfish in certain areas
that's human
I think that we just don't love each
other ourselves enough I think we I
don't know who's perfection I'm trying
to live up to like if I like silly
things like people get on me for biting
my nails gives off like people are just
creating themselves all day long rule
number three stop looking for shortcuts
for so many people that are complaining
that they don't have a big enough
audience how do you have the audacity to
wish for more fans when you don't go
into your own comments when you only get
17 of them and reply to the people that
are already part of your community from
2007 to 2011
when nobody knew who the guy was and
Twitter was the platform of the day I
spent every day replying to every single
tweet that made a mention of me and used
to go to sleep at 3 & 4 o'clock in the
morning until I completely got to
everybody and that's how I built my
foundation people want the glitz and the
glamour and the caviar but they're not
willing to eat this period if I mean if
you don't understand how this actually
plays out there is no shortcut
there's no hack there's no tip there's
just the work rule number four ignore
the opinions of others every single
thing I've ever done in my life
people thought was stupid until they did
it well because when you do something
early or that isn't mainstream yet it's
always gonna be met with cynicism the
internet was a fad when I started the
whole thing the whole internet not
flipping not Instagram the whole
framework was gonna be gone by the year
2000 all these people told me y2k is
gonna kill the Internet this is some of
the [ __ ] that I heard from like people
that didn't know rule number 5 be nice
for her first I was a super
entrepreneurial kid you know it's very
rare for somebody growing up in the 80s
who's an immigrant to not be blindly
bought into education as the way out
miraculously I have such a great mother
who saw a four five set I mean young
five six seven eight year old kid
basically spend all his time on business
lemonade you know I was a four season
executive you know in the fall I'm
raking leaves
in the winter I'm shoveling snow and
singing Christmas carols at your door I
mean I literally I don't talk about that
a lot
I literally rang people's doors I'd be
like do you want us will you pay us a
dollar to sing jingle bells me and my
crew I mean it was
and you're Jewish and I'm Jewish I mean
talk about I'm entrepreneur first you
know in the spring it was like we did a
I remember we did a miniature golf
course we did flea Mart mini flea
markets it was a garage sale
in the summer it was hardcore washing
cars of lemonade I was so passionate and
then very quickly for a lot of people
watching they'll probably remember this
in the late 80s early 90s the baseball
card phenomenon in America happened and
I was at the forefront not only was I
collecting but as a 12 year old I'm in
in hotels in malls in convention centers
set up as a dealer with other 30 40 50
year-old men and really cut my teeth
there and then my 14th birthday came and
I first whatever reason I guess that's
grown up in Russia land my dad at this
point in parellel was also an
entrepreneur more a more significant one
saved up all his money as a stock boy
and then manager of a liquor store which
is the job he got in America and bought
a liquor store and dragged me into that
liquor store in Springfield New Jersey
when I was 14 and so from eighth grade
on I worked rule number six slip stuff
one of the things I saw a lot in my
comments cuz I read them all was well I
have no money and like I lived my whole
life with no money but I figured it out
I would just buy I would buy garage
sales and it just got me going going I
love it it's like a hobby of mine to go
garage so doing it with clothes I did I
used to do a close dude the amount goes
especially like a stylish kid like you
like if you have flavor if you're
listening right now and you don't have
money but you're cool or you got flavor
you got swag you got style if you just
spend your life in goodwill and in
thrift stores yeah and by that you think
is fresh and then wear it and take a
selfie and put it on eBay for three
times the price or like I see every day
the amount of people that buy $3
t-shirts and sell them for 35 bucks on
eBay and Etsy and Facebook marketplace
is enormous
there's no excuse in America to say you
have no money even if you're in the
deepest poorest places because if you
can literally get a dollar you can buy
your first t-shirt at Goodwill
and get it up for 15 bucks on Facebook
because you know what's funny what's
funny
everybody's got a smartphone like you go
into the poorest places in America and
everybody's got a smartphone which means
you have the Internet I mean listen the
homeless
you've got people all over on home
homeless smartphones I get emails every
day I'm homeless I watch you on YouTube
rule number seven love the process I've
never done anything financial a lot of
good things have happened to me that has
remotely hit my radar more than the year
I made a hundred thousand a year I would
argue that if you really knew everything
about me
and you read it all every action I ever
did you would look me in the face and
ask me why do you sabotage yourself in
business and financials environments and
I would tell you that deep down
subconsciously I love it so much that I
just want it to happen forever and so
for me making it is is a firt you know
it just there is that's what that's what
blows me away about somebody who's like
I just need to make a million bucks and
I'm gonna go to Jamaica right or or like
I I don't have that I don't have that in
my head I just want to play forever and
that's why I'm trying to get people to
understand the process because I've it
is very clear to me that people that are
in love with their craft and process can
win and that's why I'm trying to change
the conversation around how much money
you need to be happy because it doesn't
work like I just know unbelievable
amounts of data of how many people have
lots of money how many people don't have
lots of money by our standards and how
happy they are and it doesn't take a lot
of money to be you know to be alive in
society it's about what you spend it
money on rule number eight you like
reading the comments love you do own
every video every post all day how do
you how do you deal with the negative
you someone's talking about biting your
nails empathetic mmm empathy somebody
just watched 49 seconds of me spitting
some pontification on Instagram
they've decided to make a judgment on me
and I respect that I put myself out
there they don't know everything about
me so when they dragged me down be like
this guys have made it foolish or what
the [ __ ] I'm like that makes sense
they saw me in the explore feature
they're like who's this face they watch
it they don't like it and these items
and they're not in a good place so they
have to drag down I deploy them but the
first sucks to be I would never do that
as a happy person to anybody else so hey
I'm already feel bad yeah and be who the
[ __ ] am i they only got 49 seconds and
in 49 seconds at a time
I could such in perpetuity like at 49
seconds at a time
I could be all-time terrible especially
me that gets hot and competitive and
like you know like this is how I am when
the lights come on so I deal with the
negativity with empathy to the person
that's leaving the comment a for the
fact that I feel bad because they're in
a bad place that they decided to put
more heat into the system and be like
they shouldn't do seven hours of
research of my career or Who I am as a
human being I would be upset if you
thought I was a hmm because you've had
enough interactions at this point to
have a read rule number nine have
self-awareness somebody asked me today
in an interview what do I do with my
down time I told them that I start other
businesses it's all I know it's Who I am
it's the same way when I see a teacher
or an artist or anybody when I can see
through their soul that they were meant
to cook or paint or build or whatever it
may be I get such happiness it's the
same reason that people that I went to
school with who make fifty three
thousand dollars a year but I know
they're so happy because it's what they
want they want to be home at 5 p.m. they
want to be on multiple sports teams they
want every weekend off they don't want
the pressure the greatest thing about
being a CEO founder entrepreneur is that
when there is success you get a
disproportionate amount of the credit
the
oblem with entrepreneurship is when it
fails you have nobody to blame one of
the things that I'm most worried about
is when you are a purebred entrepreneur
you don't care about losing the process
is your religion running the company is
your oxygen when you are not and you're
doing it for everybody else or because
it's cool when you fail you will have no
place to hide and your loss
will be very public and unavoidable the
reason I put so much pressure on people
being self-aware is if you're a natural
number two six thirteen or twenty-seven
the negatives of being a number one are
overwhelming and very difficult to
quantify you have to ask yourself today
that when your business fails are you
okay with the judgment of your family
friends your social media followers and
the entire world and if you are then you
can move on your merry way but if you
are not one of the great ramifications
of this golden era of entrepreneurship
is going to be the enormous amount of
depression and mental illness when 99
percent of the businesses fail and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus tip is don't let people
put you in the box
you could be everything like be like be
the greatest actor actress singer be an
accountant be be everything you can be
like it
you got wife life don't let people tweet
you know box everybody's trying to put
people box
if you're talented enough do everything
if you're Bo Jackson and Deion Sanders
play both for example I'm a good
operator and I'm a good personality so I
do both some people are good
personalities but can't run a business
some can run a business again
some people can cook and sing some
people can't they do you like if you can
do comedy and music then go if you're
good enough you'll always get it the
rock was arrested now he's a movie star
well I'm it was a rapper then he was a
movie star Marky Mark was a he was a
movie star like if you're a shoot
Kutcher was an actor now he's a baller
businessman if you're good enough
nobody's gonna stop you now I've got a
really special bonus tip from Gary on
how to be in control of your destiny
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that is time for the three-point
landing question it's time to move from
just watching another video to taking
action in your life for business and if
you're feeling bold leave your answers
in the comments below here we go
question number one what box how people
put you in that you need to escape from
number two who is opinions did you need
to stop listening to and number three
where do you most loved the process in
your business I'm unbelievably
passionate about happiness not about
money
as a matter fact I'm unbelievably not
motivated by money I've come to learn
that about myself in the last a half
decade because I'm leaving a lot of
money on the table I'm I'm motivated by
the process I'm motivated by waking up
in the morning and being fired up
because I'm in control of my destiny and
I get to do what I want I always wanted
to be in business I always wanted to
sell from the beginning from the womb
and I love the chase I love the process
which is why you're the serial
entrepreneur 100%
if you want more garyvee took at the top
50 world's video I made on him the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
cuz they're on the phone anymore and you
could talk about a day and age when it
was simpler and nicer and all this
nobody gives up
[Applause]